what do you like about playing chess 960
chests 960 is something that gives you a
chance to be creative right away it's
something that I view as an ideal form
of a game of chess because you get this
art and sport immediately in the game
you know the science is taken away from
the game so I kind of like it a lot it
saves me the hassle preparation and I'm
no longer professional player and I have
no time and energy to study openings and
just do all sorts of preparation that is
absolute must for top professional
player 916 if it offers opportunities to
create the very early stage of the game
and then you know then I'm always having
fun play chess so 960 is the is the only
option for me to compete with the best
place in the world I enjoy playing is
just kind of just very much because
there is no duty there is no knowledge
is you just come play have enjoy you
have to be more creative somehow and
it's also for me it's kind of a new
experience still I only play a few
matches and it's always nice when you
have to do something new so it's in
general very very interesting experience
it allows for much freer expression of
your understanding and lack of theory
just sort of lets you lets you fly a lot
a lot freer than than the classical
chest we have to more or less things
from move zero move one and that's far
more creative and for for us for the
professional chess players I think it's
more fun even I have so little
experience chess960 and that's one of
things I like about it that it's kind of
new it's a fresh fresh thing for me the
only over the board experience I have is
playing Hikaru and I felt like in
general he was better prepared for them
like out of the opening I was never
getting a good position there plenty of
times where you start the game moving
upon and then moving a queen or moving
upon the moving a rook and in normal
trust you literally can't do that it's
that you just violate opening principles
we have basic rules from having played
chess for four or 500 years and so just
the just the originality being able to
come up with different ideas from the
very very start is what I like the most
the amount of weirdness you get on onto
the board by most I don't know five in
many cases is just remarkable and it
it's it's a very very pleasant change
from from what we've been doing in the
classical chest unfortunately the last
century to deteriorate advanced too much
too much in my opinions and the
computers got really strong and it did
the normal chess we play now is it's
lost a bit of its charm I would say it's
not that I prefer it Fisher random but
it has disadvantage that we start
thinking of one and we can create and
it's always a new position this presents
a whole new set of challenges and these
days I kind of actively go in search of
new challenges because
that probably is my major motivation
remaining just finding new things I
haven't tried and trying them and 960 is
just absolutely perfect in that respect
[Music]
you